of course it goes without saying that
Roman power was brutal
is all ancient cultures were horribly
brutal in our standards
the campaigns of Alexander the so-called
great on mentioned by Boris The Athenian
massacre at Milos unmentioned by Boris
and the wars of Julius Caesar and Gaul
understandably unmentioned by Boris
seemed to me to make a pretty much a
score draw when it comes to sheer
nastiness
and um even the Greeks by the way as
soon as they discovered gladiatorial
games they went for them absolutely
fantastically and they converted all
their nice stadia into gladiatorial
Arenas but happily this isn't they did
I'll show you what in Ephesus
but this isn't a contest in niceness
because if it were we might not find a
winner
my support of the Romans rests on quite
different things it's about how they
grappled with issues of civil liberty
and electoral politics how they managed
to service Urban living on a vast scale
and how they consistently Incorporated
rather than excluded people whether that
was offering a role for women almost
unknown in the ancient world apart from
spotter or whether it was welcoming
migrants and creating new citizens
in fact I hope that everyone will take
away tonight one date that should rival
1066 in the consciousness of the British
and that is 212 A.D
it's the year when the emperor caracala
gave full Roman citizenship to all free
inhabitants of the Roman Empire who
didn't already have it that meant 30
million people got Roman citizenship at
a stroke it was the biggest Grant of
citizenship in the history of the planet
and it made everyone even in this
Backwater Province fully and formally
part of the wider world
right
but let's start with Liberty
libertas the distinctive Roman watchword
meaning freedom from impression freedom
in law and the freedom of the individual
in the face of the state the watchword
that powered the greatest Revolutions of
the modern world
the American and the French
Liberty egalite and fraternity had
nothing whatsoever to do with ancient
Greece is entirely Roman
but Liberty for the Romans was not just
a simple periclean slogan
leaving aside all the kind of
pontification
the real point for me is that the Romans
were the first people systematically to
debate the limit the limits of political
Liberty they faced head-on the
unanswerable questions that matter now
to us most
how far should the rights and the
freedom of the individual citizen be
suspended in the interests of Homeland
Security
big moment for Romans came in 63 BC when
the consul Cicero claimed he had
Unearthed a terrorist plot to eliminate
the government and to destroy Rome
he executed the presumed terrorists
without trial
first he was heroized
soon he was exiled precisely because he
had used the provision of a prevention
of terrorism act to justify summary
execution and they put up a shrine of
Liberty on this site of his house
Romans wrangled about that forever after
and they used arguments that still
provide a framework when we discuss
Guantanamo Bay or drone strikes on
British citizens who are fighting for
Isis and they've never been more
appointed than they are in this week
those Roman issues are are issues they
were barely raised in ancient Greece
Liberty is not of course as Boris would
say the same as democracy and Romans
never claimed to be a democracy
um which was a kind of newfangled
old-fangled Greek invention but Liberty
did underpin a form of popular power in
Rome that lasted longer and started
earlier than the short-lived democracy
of ancient Athens which soon became
under the uh the overarching power of
the Royals in Macedon never mind all the
Greek cities that were never democracies
at all the half a millennium from 509 BC
the Roman people were the Sovereign body
in the state with the freedom to elect
whoever they wanted
now you only have to listen to Cicero's
brother offering advice on how to canvas
for election at Rome to see how we have
inherited the Roman brand of politics
here he is
I must tell you no about the other parts
of your campaign in particular how you
get the electorate on your side
you have to learn The Knack of
remembering people's names
and an easy manner
you have to be seen everywhere be
generous and get a good reputation
and you have to have a create a sense of
hope for the future of the country
whatever else you do make sure you
recognize the voters
or make it look like you do
then just suppose there's some desirable
quality you don't have
pretend you do and make it look natural
flattery might be a pretty shabby thing
in general but when you're standing for
election it's essential
and make sure that you have a face an
expression and style of conversation
that matches the different expectations
of the people that you meet
people like to have things promised to
them
so if you're asked to sign up to
something you can't do either extricate
yourself politely or promise it anyway
the former is the mark of a good man the
latter the mark of a good candidate
the other thing you have to think about
is your reputation and public opinion
make sure you put all your efforts into
being a good canvasser and and make sure
that people talk about you as being a
nice guy
that they're always coming to your house
that you look the part
and that the electorate feel they're
sharing in your Fame
your campaign has to be glamorous
but you have to dig up the dirt too
if you can
see that some accusations of crime
expenses fiddling or a sex scandal are
thrown at your Rivals
it is to the Romans in other words that
we owe not so much the invention of
dirty dealing because the Athenians have
been great at cheating in elections
but that right down to earth realism
about how electoral processes operate in
fact one little greek princeling in the
second century BC observed how
canvassing went on in Rome was so in so
impressed that when he got back to his
own kingdom he actually tried going
around the common people and shaking
their hands and trying to win their
support
all it gave him amongst his own Greek
subjects was the nickname Bonkers right
but let's move on to the city itself
classical Athens was a very small place
they were perhaps 40 000 people not all
citizens living in the city itself that
makes it roughly the size of the
University of Manchester
Rome by the first century BC is a
multicultural bilingual world as many
people speaking Greek as they spoke
Latin as their first language and the
city of Rome itself was the home to a
million people it was the biggest city
in the west until 19th century London
the Romans were committed to make Urban
living modern style work
and in modern style 2 they were
committed to moaning about the
tribulations
of City Life and here's the curmudgeonly
saturis juvenile complaining about not
being able to get to sleep
insomnia causes most deaths here the
complaint itself being brought on by
indigestion rich food lying on a stomach
sore with heartburn show me the
apartment
that lets you sleep
in this city sleep costs Millions
and that's the root of the trouble the
lorries thundering past and those narrow
twisting streets the Oaths of delivery
men caught in a traffic jam would Rouse
a dozing seal
or even the mayor
if a tycoon has an appointment he rides
there in a big litter
he can read or take notes or snooze as
he jogs along
those drawn blinds are most soporific
even so he outstrips us
however fast we pedestrians May hurry
crowds surge ahead those behind us buff
at my rib cage poles poke into me one
loud swings a Cross Beam down on my
skull and other scores with a barrel
there are various other nocturnal perils
to be considered
it's a long way up to the rooftops
and a falling tile can brain you think
of all those cracked or leaky vessels
tossed out of the windows The Way They
smash their weight the damage they do to
the pavement you'll be thought most in
Provident a catastrophe happy fool if
you don't make your will before
venturing out to dinner
each open upstairs window along your
route at night may prove a death trap
so pray and hope poor you
that the local Housewives drop nothing
worse on your head than a bucket full of
slops
but I want to argue is not idealism
that's realism and that is us right we
have such an affinity actually with that
kind of thing that one man shows rather
successfully in the West End for weeks
and weeks just reading that stuff out to
us
it's only one side of the story Rome
devoted itself to organizing big city
life and Boris knows just how hard that
is right
they invented traffic rules they
invented planning legislation they had
running water and public lavatories and
if anyone thinks that's trivial
I suspect you ought to imagine what it
might have been like going to the lou in
5th Century Spotter and you might think
that Roman public Labs were a lot better
and Rome was the only place in the
ancient world where the state took
responsibility for ensuring its citizens
had enough to eat
and just a matter of invention it is
worth saying that Roman concrete
as in the pantheon
produced a span of a dome that was not
equaled till the 1960s right
top of the Roman agenda with a practical
issues of living together and how you
make a human Community work
finally Roman society
Incorporated those who were mostly
excluded in the ancient world most
obviously women
In classical Athens for all the Blasted
democracy women had a ghastly time they
were often segregated and they had few
rights of any sort they didn't have any
formal political rights in Rome but they
did actually sit down and eat with men
they were allowed to go out in the
street unveiled and they had more
economic independence than any women
have had in this country up to the late
19th century
but there are other ways in which women
were on the map
almost all the literature written by
them in Rome has been lost and we can
blame the medieval monks for that for
not copying it up my favorite one would
have been the autobiography of Nero's
mother agrippina which I think would
have told us quite a lot about the life
of the Court undermined your argument
but
it'll be good to have you know
what does survive from Rome what does
survive
all kinds of attempts admittedly by men
to construct a variety of female voices
in Greek and Latin not just suffering
heroines ridiculous parodies or
love-lorn females
I'm going to ask you to try this spoof
letter written in the third Century A.D
and ghosted for a feisty prostitute
complaining that her favorite lover has
given her up in favor of philosophy
laughs
ever since you got it into your head to
study philosophy
serious kind of guy with those horrible
knotted eyebrows
you wander off to the university with
some old book in your hands and you walk
right past my place as if you'd never
seen it before
you've gone mad my boy
don't you realize what kind of person
that professor of yours is
who looks so dreadfully severe when he
delivers those amazing lectures to you
students
how long do you think he's been
pestering me for a date
when he's already wrecking himself for
the lovely herpes
I turned him down because I'd rather
sleep with you than take the money of
all the professors in the world
but since he seems to be putting you off
me perhaps I will ask him in and then
I'll be able to tell you what that
perverted old misogynist is really like
anyway
do you think a professor is really that
much different from an escort girl
they have different means of persuasion
Maybe
but honestly they have the same aim
earning across
we girls are much better and more
God-fearing than the props know we don't
say that gods don't exist
we believe our lovers when they swear
they love us
and we don't think men should sleep with
their sisters or their mothers or even
other men's wives
seem not quite up to the academics
because we don't know where the clouds
come from and what atoms look like
but no one who spends time with us ends
up dreaming of revolution
overthrowing the state
in fact they tend to stay in bed rather
late in the morning sleeping off the
night before
you might even say that we are better
than the props at educating the Young
for after all
God doesn't give us very long to live
don't waste it on riddles and academic
nonsense in that Ivory Tower of yours
now for me that is Roman culture all
over it's fun it's warm and it's raising
more important points than you might
think without all the fuss and
pretension
it's asking how do people learn
does philosophy really make us better
human beings or not
But ultimately it was not
just the incorporation of women into the
state into a role in the state but it
was the incorporation of new citizens
into the state Rome had a mechanism for
becoming Roman
now classical Athens had such an
exclusive and narrowly ethnic you might
always call it racist policy on who
could become a citizen but if we were
using their rules are not even certain
that Boris would be a UK citizen I mean
you were born in New York weren't you I
think that could be a problem and
apparently right
and what we would have lost
but in Rome
what caracala did
and 212 A.D 212 A.D was only the final
act in a long process which started when
the founder of Rome Romulus welcomed
refugees and Asylum Seekers to his new
city by the Tiber to be proper Roman
citizens
and which carried on our citizenship was
spread among those whom Rome had at
first conquered and when people from Far
afield became Roman emperors trajan and
hadron from Spain septimius Severus from
North Africa
and at the same time slaves in their
Millions
were freed at Rome
and in the process completely unlike in
the Greek World they became
full Roman citizens many fewer slaves
were ever freed in Athens or any of the
Greek States in which we know
um and if they were freed they certainly
didn't become citizens this was an
incorporating Community now some
observant people in Greece early on
spotted these weird habits of the Romans
and they were amazed
smartest
began to think that maybe Roman openness
was the secret of her success
and that's what I think I think too I
think Rome's real Rome's rough it's in
your face it open it's welcoming and
it's us